[موسيقى] كم عمرها ، إنه يوم مهم بالنسبة إلى قسباوي العار والذي يمكن أن يحدد مستقبل شركتها الناشئة ، لذا نحن اليوم في مركز الأطفال ، من المثير حقًا أن نرى كل هؤلاء السيدات يتجهن إلى أطفالهن الصغار في 2017 دبي- بدأت العار المستندة إلى تشغيل تطبيق جوال حيث يقوم الآباء ببناء دائرة اجتماعية لأطفالهم قبل جائحة الفيروس التاجي ، استضافت شركتها بانتظام أحداثًا للأطفال مثل هذه ، فقد كانت هذه هي المفتاح لنموذج أعمالها ، حيث شكل العاران اللذان ينظمان كل شهر 80 بالمائة من عائدات الشركة. أنت تحب ، شكرًا جزيلاً على حضوركم. تجمع اليوم هو الأول منذ ما يقرب من عام ، إنها فرصة لشميم لاختبار المياه التي تبدو وكأنها مختلفة ليقول أن أقل عدد من الحضور قد تم تحديده بـ 25 سعة عادية والأقنعة مطلوبة من الشركات مثل playdate ذلك المعتمد على اللقاءات وجهًا لوجه تضررت بشدة بشكل خاص من عمليات الإغلاق المرغوبة والتباعد الاجتماعي ، وكثير من الأشخاص يخرجون من العمل عادةً
وقوع حدث لمدة 48 ساعة في هذا الحدث
ليس كثيرًا لأن الآباء
قلقون من
[الموسيقى]
لأن جانب الأحداث من عملها أدى إلى تجفيف
الشميم لاستراتيجيتها لإيجاد طرق
جديدة لجلب الأموال
التي تبنيها ميزة إضافية
على تطبيقها  لاستيعاب
تواريخ اللعب الافتراضية ، وهو أمر
كان مستخدموها يسألون عنه ،
كيف حالك ، كيف حالك ، كيف حالك؟
وكالات التسويق عبر وكلاء
إنهم منفتحون على الأفكار الجديدة ،
لذا فقد حظينا بفرحة كبيرة لوجود
العديد من العلامات التجارية
التي يحتاجون إليها للوصول إلى المستهلكين
ونمنحهم إمكانية الوصول إلى عائلات حقيقية
هناك سيأتي وقت يستضيف فيه شميم
أحداثًا كهذه مرة أخرى
ولكن ليس بعد فقط حتى
يتم تخفيف إجراءات التباعد الاجتماعي ويستعيد العملاء
ثقتهم ،
تقول شميم إنها ستواصل إيجاد
طرق جديدة لكسب المال
وتحافظ على تفاعل المستخدمين معها ، من الضروري
أن تلعب دور نجاح جون ديفتريوس سي إن إن
دبي